it is interesting you know the micro
physical realm this would be one escape
for us and our cultural dilemma some of
you may know a wonderful science fiction
book called uh by brian aldis called the
long afternoon of earth
which is about a world where
people are four and a half inches high
and the world is covered by a banyan
forest from pole to pole and somehow you
know in order to live in this savage
jungle environment the decision was made
at some point long in the past before
technology was lost to go through this
shrinking process and so people are very
tiny and
but we could
like a good
nanotechnology
male patriarch engineering mission type
goal to lay before the research and
development community would be
something which i envisioned to be like
a pair of black
contact lenses
which you would have surgically
implanted in the inner eyelid
and then when you closed your eyes
there would be menus hanging in space
and
what this would be is this would be the
cultural interface device
into a culture which was entirely
virtual sustained in electromagnetic
hologrammatic
hyperspace
and the only access technology would be
these black
contact lenses in in behind your eyelids
and so you would appear to be basically
ronnie you know naked painted walking
around in the rain forest but when you
closed your eyes you would be
able to
send and receive faxes scan databases
thousands of miles away
receive email
uh look at your bank balance uh play
games play games talk to people at a
distance exchange information have
virtual sexy you know all these things
that are promised but the culture would
have been dematerialized this is a key
thing we have and again psychedelics are
important because psychedelics show the
power of the imagination that it where
we want to go live
is the imagination you know there's real
estate out there folks and you want to
get there first and stake your claim
[Laughter]
but they'd be balanced by the radical
traditionalists who viewed technology as
a crude literalization of innate human
capacity and these two groups could in
fact you know um coexist and in fact
trade off but the but the but the
radical traditionalists would be devoted
to the restoration of the gene pool and
would prefer their technology to be more
of a telepathic nature by preference but
it would be nice to have exchanges
between these groups but i think two
groups so that we so we again were
wedded to the material and embracing it
rather than distance more well the
beauty of it would be that the only
difference between these two groups
would be you'd have to grab somebody
hold them down and peel back their
eyelid
and then if they were wearing the lens
you'd know they were a radical
technocrat and if they weren't you'd
know that they were a radical
traditionalist and otherwise there would
be no difference
yeah right rad trad
[Laughter]
but don't you actually think that once
information or once
technology is no longer manifest in
matter
it will come to look much more like
nature
in other words the reason technology has
straight lines and all that is these are
engineering constraints dictated by
gravity and design if you could if
information were made of light it would
look very much like the rain forest
and then you would like transcend the
dualism of nature and technique and it
would just be one
weird thing
but there may well be a co-evolution in
the sense of everything pulsing together
that as the technology becomes outwardly
manifest the inner telepathic capacity
cove they mutually co-evolve at the same
time but i think one without the other
is the atlantean fallacy
well the jungle at night seems very very
electrical and electronic and you can
tell that there's infrared signals and
the databases are cycling and power is
being used because peak users have gone
offline and
just all these homeostatic regulators
are working even for those of us who
haven't yet had the implants
yes that's what i'm saying that's right
yeah well we're headed somewhere i mean
i think that what people don't realize
is that
business as usual is off the menu
there's no
even the straight people the data which
crosses their desks on human population
research
resource extraction
epidemic diseases toxification of the
environment retreat of species it's
hap it's happening the spin down
to something is underway and then the
question is you know what is it is it
just grim death and we turn the planet
into a weedy lot and then that's it or
what about all this transcendental
appetite for
cosmic breakthrough that also
accompanies it it it's very hard to
be a rational person
and tell where it's going here's the
blue butterfly
yeah we'll see i think the rate of
acceleration is so intense that it's
inconceivable that there's a human
future even measured in hundreds of
years
it's it's all
this is it
you know the collision is actually
happening in slow motion before your
startled eyes the end of the second
millennium and western civilization is
completely
exhausted
it hasn't a clue all these wonderful
methods that were going to lead us to
platonic truth and union with god and
the gates of the heavenly city you know
the gates of the heavenly city is
spanish harlem and
god looks like a psychotic on crack so
we have to sort of back off to the
archaic
moment which was the last sane moment
that we ever knew before we committed
ourselves to this
shell game launched by the monotheists
and their stooges and so forth we've
already had mr 666 as president for
eight years
[Laughter]
see i think that i mean
that the idea that something is going to
transform reality beyond recognition
at first
when seen through the eyes of of
probability theory and positivism seems
miraculous and unlikely because you say
well surely the end of the world happens
only once every five billion years so
what are the odds that i will see it in
my
70 year span of life but that's
not the right approach
because
uh
novelty begets novelty
and the presence of human history
as a part of what's going on here and
now on this planet is like the rippling
on the surface
of a of a body of water immediately
before some enormous form
breaks through from beneath human
history is the enunciation call of the
approaching singularity i mean if if the
singularity were not approaching we
would still be happily hurling excrement
at each other in the canopies of african
rainforest it is the approach of the
breakthrough being felt anticipated
across four or five million years of
evolution that draws us to erect the
fragile tools of mathematics and radio
telescopy and all this other stuff in
order to be there to catch the fly ball
when it falls into our mint you see
so we
are the proof
of the presence of the other in the
planetary ecology otherwise there would
just be squirrel monkeys brine shrimp
and antelope you know but we represent
something else pushing into the
biological realm
mind purpose intentionality
for some reason and you know then the
chrysters and all the rest leap forward
to explain why it is but nobody knows
why it is they just flail you with some
laundry list of moral do's and don'ts
that's where they come out with it but
what it is is it's a complete mystery
but something is
shaping us
to its own vision of what we should be
history is not pushed by causal momentum
toward entropy history is pulled in
ever-tightening gyre toward
confrontation with the attractor that is
its
maker
and toward which it vectors across
hundreds of thousands of years
it's a it's something odd loose
here and the use of language and the
production of art and magic and shamanic
vision and high technology all these
things are feedback
telling you there's a very weird form of
radiation
in the neighborhood you know we've gone
beyond uh the birds and the bees here to
something else and the something else is
growing it's an embryo of some sort it's
in process of concrescence whitehead's
word concrescence it has an appetite for
uh
expressing itself as a nexus of novel
connections civilization based on animal
organization based on the biosphere
based on the geology of the planet based
on the dynamics of the solar system you
know something reaching out toward
itself and we are it's the stuff
with which it mirrors itself weird
we pull
back at it of course i mean the sense
that we vote for reality with our
imagination
so what so when people i mean well are
we thinking it up to some degree we are
i mean in the sense that technology
every asp every artifact of technology
began as an idea in a human mind and
technology is now
shaping the destiny of the planet this
means ideas born in the human mind are
now shaping the destiny of the planet
well what is the human mind and what is
it about the human brain mind body
triad that allows us to download these
ideas
into the stream of cosmic
consequentiality i mean antelope don't
do that caiman don't do that nobody else
is downloading ideas into the
the swift running current of cosmic
unfoldment everybody else is playing the
old evolutionary solitaire game with
gene mutation environmental pressure so
forth and so on we've invented a new
game
well this is the this is the question
this is another reality of which we are
the construct and the development of or
the experiment
are we growing toward a dissolution of
the boundary between this world and some
other world is it the world beyond death
that the shaman and the seers and all
these people rave about does the human
soul
actually is it indestructible or does it
survive
the morphology of the body and then
in what dimension and under what
constraints and toward what purpose
i mean it's all
questions nothing is secure i mean
science has
told us very little of what we actually
are interested in when we think about
how we're born out of blackness and
go down into the earth after a very
short time you know you just get a
glimpse it's like a dmt trip
you barely get your sea legs before
they're saying
deja vu
so since nothing's secure in the dream
mind body we are the seeds of the
children of the unborn world
it sounds good to me there's a line in a
christian hymn that i like in the sweet
by and by shall we meet on that
beautiful shore
that's it
by the water of babylon
preparing for disembodiment you know i
think a lot of that there's a big
there's a lot of people believe in that
you mean the glory and
not the rapture not that disembodiment
not the rest not those not with those
people
who are well but all of these are
different takes
they're all different takes on this
intimation of an ontological bolt of
lightning
it could happen
it could happen
long as the long is the faith
but looks what's come and gone i mean
much has come and gone since our the
mushroom munching ancestors of the
african dawn moment
and we say the world never changes but
on the other hand you know
babylon is ruins and
so much has happened and in such a
little bit of time i mean 10 000 years
ago
the curtain had barely risen and then
just like
the monkeys go berserk
and before you know it instruments are
being hurled out of the solar system the
human genome is being probed radiation
levels are rising the ozone holes
disappearing the ice caps are in retreat
it's like they just pulled the plug ten
thousand years it's as catastrophic as
an asteroid impact from the point of
view of most
ecosystems you know just blam the slow
collision not this time with an iron you
know a condraceous chondrite but with a
mind
mind arose on this planet or came to
this planet or emerged out of this
planet or something but the moment that
it did in its ability to non-epigenetic
to non-genetically express itself you
know codes there was some breakthrough
in coding ability and and information
manipulation and they were off to the
races
and the momentum of these processes is
now virtually unstoppable
nobody
knows where this is all going and
there's no plan
there's no plan
you